but first tonight an exclusive
investigation from this show for two
years the alleged threat that Russia
poses to our elections has been official
Washington's obsession the usual
business of government has come to a
halt as Democrats and their allies in
the press fret that Russian agents may
be interfering with our democracy
the root of these fears a handful of
Russian ads on Facebook that almost
nobody saw in a small number of efforts
to hack Democratic Party email accounts
now let's assume that all these deeply
worried people are sincere that they
really care about the integrity of our
democracy then why is almost nobody say
to anything about the tech monopolies
that now dominate the exchange of
information in this country if a few
dozen Facebook ads are enough to subvert
an election shouldn't we be worried
about Facebook itself which controls
literally billions of ads a couple of
times on this show social scientists
Robert Epstein has pointed out that
Google alone could determine the outcome
of almost any American election just by
altering its search suggestions we'd
never know what happened
oh say tech defenders don't worry these
are businesses they exist to make money
not to push political agendas well it
turns out that's not true and we can
prove it an email obtained exclusively
by this show reveals that a senior
Google employee deployed the company's
resources to increase voter turnout in
ways she believed would help the Clinton
campaign win in the last election the
email we obtained came from a woman
named Eliana Murray Oh
the former head of Google's
multicultural marketing department she
sent the email on November 9th 2016 that
was one day after the presidential
election that email was subsequently
forwarded by to Google vice president's
two more staff members throughout the
company in her email maria maria touts
google's multifaceted efforts to boost
Hispanic turnout in the election
she knows that Latinos voted in
record-breaking numbers especially in
states like Florida Nevada and Arizona
the last of which she describes as quote
a key state for us she brags that the
company used its power to ensure that
millions of people saw certain hashtag
and social media impressions with the
goal of influencing their behavior
during the election elsewhere in the
email murió says google quote supported
partners like voto Latino to pay for
rides to the polls in key states she
describes this assistance as quote a
silent donation Mario then says that
Google helped voto Latino create ad
campaigns to promote those rides now
officially voto Latino is a nonpartisan
entity but that is a sham voto Latino is
vocally partisan recently the group
declared that Hispanics all Hispanics
are in president Trump's quote
crosshairs they said they plan to
respond to this by registering another
million additional Hispanic voters in
the next presidential cycle voter Latino
is a group with clear political goals
goals that Google supported in 2016 we
asked both Google and voto Latino for
clarification
what exactly did Maria mean by a silent
donation this is a potentially
significant legal question neither
company responded to us at the end of
her email Moreno makes it clear that
Google was working to get Hillary
Clinton elected this wasn't a
get-out-the-vote effort whatever they
say it was not aimed at all potential
voters it wasn't even aimed at a
balanced cross-section of subgroups
Google didn't try to get out the vote
amongst a Christian Arabs in Michigan or
Persian Jews in Los Angeles they
sometimes vote Republican it was aimed
only at one group a group that Google
cynically assumed would vote exclusively
for the Democratic Party furthermore
this mobilization effort targeted not
the entire country but swing states
vital to the Hillary campaign this was
not an exercise in civics this was
political consulting it was in effect an
in-kind contribution to the Hillary
Clinton for president campaign in the
end Google was disappointed as Maria
herself conceded quote ultimately after
all was said and done the Latino
community did come out to vote and
completely surprised us we never
anticipated that 29% of Latinos would
vote for Trump no one did
if you see a Latino Googler in the
office please give them a smile they are
probably hurting right now you can rest
assured that the latinos of these blues
need your thoughts and prayers for them
and their families I had planned a
vacation and thought it would be taking
the time to celebrate now it will be
time to reflect on how to continue to
support my community through these
difficult times
end quote nobody at the DNC was more
upset by the results than Maria who will
try to get Hillary elected they failed
this time we reached out to Google the
company did not deny that the email was
real or that it showed a clear political
preference their only defense was that
the activities it described for either
non nonpartisan or weren't taken
officially by the company but of course
they were both plenty of people in
Google knew what was going on and we've
seen no evidence that anyone at Google
disapproved of it or tried to rein it in
two years later Google is more powerful
than it's ever been and the left has
increasingly become radical in what it
is willing to do to regain political
power
what do Google be doing this election
cycle to support its preferred
candidates what could they do in 2020 is
a question almost nobody in Washington
seems interested in even asking they
ought to be interested